oui un retour inattendu celui de
l'ancien rappeur elle ferait une
opération festival de cannes pour
présenter un documentaire qui s'appelle
salam qui veut dire
bienvenue en arabe
avaient déjà bloqué sur bon anniversaire
aux deux fois non j'allais à bloquer au
contraire salam bienvenus bienvenue
exactement
ya les choix qu'il ya un an 6,7 et
shalom la pixma pardon
en compétition officielle et aigri
séances spéciales et donc elle a donné
une interview où elle revient à travers
un film documentaire bouleversant le
raconte à coeur ouvert à tous la
dépression voilà tout ce qu'on va on va
ce qu'on va voir dans ce dans ce
documentaire elle a déjà misé sur
instagram un petit message pour
remercier voilà les fans
voilà qu'on voit ici à nancy voilà mais
souvent ma reconnaissance un film et
divertissement elle a posté ça moi je
suis fan total en comptant sa dépression
mais qui amènera du monde lui a eu beau
rap français qui s'appelle et si c'était
le dernier c'est magique et avant
d'avoir toutes les infos sur skyrock
notamment grâce à florian samakuva de sa
dernière interview c'était en 2012 dans
cet axe est à 8 voilà où elle raconte
pourquoi elle s'en va
l'arrivée de deux du statut de star
qui ne me convenait pas enfin vraiment
on aura beau dire tout ce qu'on veut
parce que je sais que plein de gens qui
veulent pas croire aux discours mais non
attends tu as dû qui fait et tout certes
j'ai essayé de kiffer mais j'y suis
jamais arrivé tout ce que quelqu'un
arrivait d'avoir dans une vidéo star je
l'aï eu j'ai cru un ce rêve est
effectivement c'est un événement en fait
je dis je n'avais pas la grosse tête
mais j'en avais tous les symptômes
j'étais tellement obnubilé obnubilé par
la petite personne que bunge en oublier
les autres
encore
j'aimerais tellement qu'elle croque tout
le monde se pose effectivement c est ce
que c'est juste à un documentaire voilà
pas contenir après par rapport aux fans
c'est ça ou est ce qu'il ya un désir de
revenir gameiro désir 020 et elle sera
pas canon +1 les gens alors les gens
s'entassent bien sûrement sur sa venue
mais ça serait tellement incohérent avec
son mode de vie aujourd'hui les strass
les paillettes le tapis rouge la montée
des marches pas du tout en fait elle
voulait ce livre et parce qu'elle
voulait pas que ce soit d'autre personne
qui raconte son histoire qui raconte
c'est sa détresse sa souffrance sa
tentative de suicide et tout ça elle a
repris sa plume entouré de deux femmes
formidables dont 1,6 et d'ailleurs mais
elle ne reviendra pas pas du tout c'est
notamment le par le site sa conversion à
l'islam excellent grand mère décédée
elle-même tellement de choses voilà une
phrase que j'ignore ce qui va me dire
c'est même ma mère m'appelait diam's et
noir et puis mélanie elle était complète
energain complètement perdu oui florian
vous avez rencontrées vous alors moi
j'ai fait aussi ses s'intéresse
d'interaction de l'avoir de la voir
comme ça parce que moi j'ai fait pas mal
de soirées avec elle où elle était dans
des tenues relativement sexy elle buvait
du champagne
fallait la voir en soirée elle pouvait
avoir un petit débardeur
s'habille aujourd'hui c'est quand même
très différent donc en tout cas on était
là pour dire qu'elle était vraiment à
des années lumières du voilà du
personnage qu'on convoque on découvre
aujourd'hui fin qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et non moi ce qui est
intéressant je vais revenir sur le
documentaire sur la façon dont il a été
pensé déjà elle a travaillé aussi avec
houda ben yamina on a connu dandine
multi césarisé et c'est à cannes c'était
l'une de ces conditions aussi c'était
que ce soit diffusé au festival de
cannes parce qu'elle a un lien
particulier avec ce festival là est
aussi ça fout le signal et ça va être
sur brut ixquick forme façon streaming
netflix et c'est quelque chose de
relativement nouveau moi je me suis
laissé dire contrairement à ce que dit
ludivine qui avait un désir ah oui de
réhabilitation derrière tout ça alors
après pas pour revenir sur scène pour
chanter etc mais d'une autre façon ça
c'est certain et moi je pense que c'est
possible si je pense que c'est possible
s'est pas fait alors justement la forme
je pense qu'on va là qu'on va la
découvrir pendant le festival de cannes
après la diffusion de ce oui
bien sûr a dit elle a un lien
particulier les cannes lequel oui c'est
ce que j'ai alors elle a toujours aimé
le festival de cannes doit enfin
l'article est d'aimer festival le gall
elle connaît mes attentes diam's quand
elle quand elle disparaît des radars
elle connaît tout le monde elle connaît
dans le cinéma français elle connaît
thierry frémaux lé voilà elle est allée
à cannes plusieurs fois faire la fête
mais pas que c'était une vraie business
woman donc dans le cinéma très chic ce
qu'elle fait comme revenir à une
interview abruti
jeudi c'est à dire qu'elle voulait pas
que ce soit comme a pu le faire anelka
par exemple sur sur netflix un dock qui
arrive comme un rat sans prévenir et
puis qui disparaît aussi vite qu'il
arrive là c'est une première mondiale au
festival de cannes il faut préciser que
c'est le premier festival de cannes le
premier vrai depuis trois ans oui après
une année blanche et un festival un ps
conserve divine ce que tu as fait pour
que tu la connais bien je l'aï
rencontrée elle avait fait un concert
aux antilles à l'époque où j'étais
animatrice sur nrj anti d'accord j'avais
eu la grande chance de pouvoir la voir
en l'émission est ce qu'on va savoir
dans le dock des trucs du quotidien elle
habite où elle vit ou celle de se
raconter vous savez ça sera un dock un
peu à l'instar de ce qu'a fait naître
fixe pour johnny d'accord elle va se
raconter au travers d' image d'elle-même
qu'elle vaille view aujourd'hui par là
une maison
les enfants des soldes jour des revenus
de la musique depuis dix ans elle vit de
ça elle a toujours aussi sa fondation
pour aider l'afrique elle fait plein de
choses duquel est aussi exact elle fait
du tourisme du tourisme religieux
également pour aller découvrir la mecque
et tous nos médias écrits déjà terminé à
l'écouté des chansons encore elle écrit
des chansons quand même préciser qu'elle
est avec un ancien rappeur aussi à la
wii il appelle fawaz it arkanic avait
sorti une chanson des années 90 oui il
parlait du fait qu'il était atteint de
cécité quelqu'un qui a perdu la vue et
c'est un rap d'heure assez aveugle assez
intéressant et donc voilà faut aussi
préciser lequel telli mardi à l'islam
fascinant aussi c'est cette machine à
broyer un autre niveau ridicule mais
quand c'est des zénith dé bercy que tu
as vingt mille personnes qui crie ton
nom donc fait envie de mourir parce
qu'il le dit elle dit qu'elle avait
envie de mourir et si on était très sale
année
finalement sa seule échappatoire ça a
été la religion sinon elle serait le dl
serait mort bien sûr on
va regarder un extrait de son ex qui
parle d'elle mais juste avant il va
alors justin bieber on aime ou on n'aime
pas mais comme quand tu as une telle
renommée pendant le coc vide il est un
peu tombé dans les bouches du stupéfiant
et y racontait que quand tous les soirs
tu chantes devant trente mille personnes
et que tu reçois comme ça une décharge
d'amour et tout ça quand ça s'arrête
rentrer chez toi retrouver ta copine
c'était très lasagnes c'est il ya un
passage qui est très bien
la raison de l'action catholique à ce
moment là at elle résumé regardez
l'expression mariko des raisons la
patience des oreilles suivez son
confident j'ai par exemple m dunn qui me
dit tu sais mon nom je m'appelle pu
mélanie
à ma peine vient est ce que tu as eu
peur pour ma wii
je suis je me suis dit c'est trop payé 2
je me dis c'est trop
c'est trop quoi
c'est une souffrance à l'ex-homme ses
souffrances de cette souffrance
est issu le pourquoi du coup ça c'était
un très beau documentaire de mon ami
guillaume genton une seule rappeuse en
france si diam's il ne cèdera jamais été
remplacé il y en avait pas
elle est où ce dossier
est rien mais vous savez que les fans de
gamme sont aussi émus voire plus ému
encore que nous je sais pas si vous avez
vu le déferlement de messages oui mais
les gens ils disent ils se filment en
train de dire en pleurant c'est la plus
grande la plus belle nouvelle de l'année
paru pour eux de revoir leurs gammes sur
les écrans c'est extraordinaire mais
vraiment et donc comme moi je quand elle
était venue chanter marine sur batman
fogiel à l'époque j'étais assistant non
j'étais à côté de ça mais quel charisme
et puis quelle gentillesse elle était là
à les éviter un peu comme données
d'essais très douce et puis tout d'un
coup la chanson par et à la bête de
scène exactement à une bête de scène tu
connais ça finalement part car bien sûr